hey i'm john cena hbo's peacemaker and
these are some moments from my life
[Music]
this is an action shot from a wwe event
wrestlemania when i see images i kind of
go back to how i felt right now i'm
probably feeling exhausted and satisfied
because i know we're almost done with
our performance and it's going pretty
good or at least i think it is i always
judge by like the faces of the audience
as you look at the front row and
certainly as we go back engagement and
interest especially in our referee mike
kyota's face it's good to see a photo
like that at such an impactful event and
know that your audience was engaged
because as a live performer what we do
is for the for the benefit of the
audience so when i see that shot the
first thing i look at is the audience
and it's it's good to see them engaged
i'd like to know what what's going
through the mind of dwayne no i wouldn't
like to know what's going through the
mind of dwayne johnson because he
doesn't look pleased
[Music]
so this is me in a different uniform and
this is me
in a different uniform and long ago in a
galaxy far far away there was no
peacemaker uniform and i dressed and
acted like many of the other wwe
performers until i got a chance to do
this now
this is a bit of a confusing photo
because it looks like i'm talking about
something serious while dressed probably
not as serious as the subject matter i'm
talking kind of like right now like will
years from now while i look back on this
moment and be like man i was talking
about
deep philosophical things dressed as a
man who will kill to get peace time will
tell but as i reflect back on this this
is probably because i'm still wearing
sports jerseys and a master lock around
my neck this is probably at the start of
me defining myself as the hip hop
presence in world wrestling
entertainment in wwe
[Music]
certain images spark emotions and this
one man i feel
joy a whole lot of joy this was a
celebration that the make-a-wish
foundation put together supposedly for
me to let the world know that i just
granted a 500th wish but what i remember
about this celebration is we got to
grant a bunch more wishes that day it
was before a wwe event and we got to
bring in a bunch of make-a-wish families
to a place where we could all eat and
have fun and play games and then we had
a wwe event that night it was like a
wish on top of a wish or just an added
piece of depth to the day and in an
amazing gesture wwe donated 1 million
dollars to the make-a-wish foundation
and wwe and make-a-wish have been in a
partnership now for almost 40 years i
believe i've been able to share a piece
of that partnership for almost 20 of
those 40 and we've had some great
moments and my involvement with
make-a-wish doesn't happen without wwe
and me being at the end of the wish
me being able to see the joy and the
happiness that these families and
children have when they get their wish
granted man it is really pure joy you
can't have a bad day when you're
involved with something like this and
this day certainly was no different it's
a wonderful day in my life and it's a
chance you know the wwe donated
resources to make a wish to make more
wishes that was a day we made more
wishes and that evening i got to perform
for every single family there and that
was a that was really special
[Music]
here you're lucky enough to be invited
into the home of christopher smith
that's right
this is where peacemaker lives looks
like he's had a rough day because he's
covered in dirt and blood and who else
knows what that is the brainchild behind
peacemaker james gunn and that is him
telling me that i'm not any good and
that i'll never work in this town again
and then i should move from here the
world in which people understand stuff
to overhear place where i belong or no
one understands me because i'm not any
good james used a lot of talking with
his hands when telling me i sucked
because he had the mask you couldn't
read his entire face i know true emotion
starts with the eyes and he stared
daggers through me for the most of the
production but he also accentuated his
point with his hands most of the time he
simply needed two fingers to let me know
you know his thoughts of my performance
this was a bonding moment between the
two of us as you can see me i'm looking
concerned of like by not working this
town again would he let's see
spare me the medical terms pal like tell
me you know give it to me straight so he
did and uh we continued to film for 120
days after that
[Music]
once again john cena hbo's peacemaker
and i just hope you learned a little bit
about me because i'm an onion and i
tried to peel back some layers for you
today if i failed miserably tune in next
time